one thing we learned when we were
looking at the top paid actors um of
is how much money is coming from netflix
netflix seems to be willing to really
pay a premium
for big movie stars the dwayne johnsons
the
ben afflecks the ryan reynolds of the
world and it's really paying off
five of the top 10 most watched netflix
original films
either star or are made by actors on our
list
here are the highest-paid actors of
2020.
number one is dwayne johnson the rock he
made 87.5 million dollars this year
a lot of that didn't come from netflix
he made over 20 million dollars for
red notice an upcoming film that he
co-stars in with ryan reynolds and gal
gadot
he also has a netflix film that we
didn't count this year but they clearly
love him he um is starring in an
upcoming film with emily blunt called
fall and chain
that'll be a new superhero movie for
netflix other projects include black
adam a gc comic film
he's the host of titan games on nbc he
also made eight million dollars from his
under armour line project raw
this is his second year in a row topping
our list
ryan reynolds comes in at number two
he's netflix's golden boy right now
he's starred in six underground which
was netflix's fourth most watched film
of all time
he's in the upcoming red notice with the
rock he also
sold a third movie to netflix just last
month on a time travel adventure film
but it's not just netflix apple tv plus
is also paying big money for ryan
he's rumored to be making over 30
million dollars for his upcoming role in
a christmas carol
mark wahlberg comes in at number three
um he's kind of a classic movie star he
made 58 million dollars last year
and his big netflix film was spencer
confidential it was uh the streamer's
third most watched original film of all
time
uh and he made up to 25 million dollars
on it he also
produced mcmillions um and he has an
upcoming hbo max series called wall
street
ben affleck comes in at number four with
55 million dollars in earnings
his netflix film triple frontier was in
uh 2019
and so it didn't count on this year's
list but it was on one of netflix's top
10 most watched films
he also had last thing he wanted with
the streamer this past year
and has upcoming films the last duel and
hypnotic
vin diesel made 54 million dollars in
the past year
most of that is from fast and furious
nine and he's going to make even more
after that comes out um in back-end
payments
akshay kumar is the only bollywood star
on this year's list and he made 48.5
million dollars in the past year
he is also one of the first big
bollywood stars to have a
show on a streamer um he has the end
coming to amazon prime hopefully next
year depending on the pandemic and he's
going to make 10 million dollars from
that
lin-manuel miranda made the list for the
first time he made 45 and a half
million dollars in the past year and
most of that is um from disney's 75
million dollars
acquisition of hamilton
will smith came in eighth place with 44
and a half million dollars he didn't
make any money from netflix this year
but he will be making big money from
netflix next year for bright too
it's rumored he's going to get over 30
million dollars for that role
adam sandler is one of netflix's biggest
stars he made most of his 41 million
dollars
from his deal with netflix netflix users
have spent over 2 billion hours watching
sandler's content since he first signed
a deal with the streamer in 2014.
jackie chan rounds out the list at
number 10 he made 40 million dollars
this past
year and he can command 10 million
dollars up front for a role
there are three big reasons that netflix
wants big movie stars they increase
engagement
they help retain subscribers and most
importantly movie stars
global brands help bring in subscribers
from around the world
a lot of the projects that the highest
paid actors have been paid for
haven't even begun filming yet or had to
stop filming because of the pandemic
so next year we're going to see if
they're getting more up front if filming
starts again
or if things are kind of on a stand
still until hollywood can reopen
production
you